-Performing "Sidelines"
from the Hulu series
"Conversations with Friends,"
please welcome Phoebe Bridgers.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
-♪ I'm not afraid of ♪
♪ Anything at all ♪
♪ Not dying in a fire ♪
♪ Not being broke again ♪
♪ I'm not afraid of ♪
♪ Living on a fault line ♪
♪ 'Cause nothing ever
shakes me ♪
♪ Nothing makes me cry ♪
♪ Not a plane going down ♪
♪♪
♪ In the ocean, I'm drowning ♪
♪ Watch the world
from the sidelines ♪
♪ Had nothing to prove ♪
♪ Till you came into my life ♪
♪ Gave me something to lose ♪
♪ Now I know
what it feels like ♪
♪ To wanna go outside ♪
♪ Like the shape of my outline ♪
♪♪
♪ I'm not afraid of
going back to school ♪
♪ I gave it up the first time,
but I'll try again ♪
♪ I'm not afraid of
getting older ♪
♪ Used to fetishize myself ♪
♪ Now I'm talking
to my house plants ♪
♪ Not of being alone ♪
♪ In a room full of people ♪
♪ Watching the world
from the sidelines ♪
♪ Had nothing to prove ♪
♪ Till you came into my life ♪
♪ Gave me something to lose ♪
♪ Now I know
what it feels like ♪
♪ To wanna go outside ♪
♪ Like the shape of my outline ♪
♪ And I used to think ♪
♪ You could hear the ocean
in a seashell ♪
♪ What a childish thing ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]